je vous donne aujourd'hui neuf astuces
pour bien utiliser chat GPT au-delà même
de ce que vous pensez qu'il est possible
de faire quand je publie cette vidéo on
est au mois de décembre en période de
fin d'année et qu'est-ce qu'on fait en
période de fin d'année et bien on achète
des cadeaux on fait plaisir aux gens
qu'on aime et des fois c'est compliqué
de trouver de très bonnes idées et bien
là chat GPT va vous aider non pas en
écrivant un promp directement comme ça
et moi si et ça non vous allez carrément
vous adresser presque au Père Noël de
chat GPT sur Chat GPT vous allez dans
explore et là vous allez trouver made by
open ai et bien en direct du Pôle Nord
on va avoir Santa et Santa on peut lui
poser quand même pas mal de questions à
commencer par quel est le vrai nom du
père Noël ah le vrai Père Noël dans
nombreuses tradition il est connu sous
le nom de Saint-Nicolas inspiré de
l'évêque du 4e siècon bon voilà on s'en
fout vous vous direz voir directement
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'il
m'aide à venir acheter des cadeaux à
trouver des idées de cadeaux pour ma
compagne aide-moi à trouver cinq idées
de cadeaux pour ma compagne Justine qui
aime les sacs à main les manteaux mais
aussi les Ch chaussur et on envoie oh
quelle joie de choisir des cadeaux pour
Justine les sneakers golden Go oh nom de
Dieu les prix 150 € c'est totalement
hors budget des converses pour femmes je
sens que ça va être un petit peu plus
abordable bon là il y a plein de
converses différentes si ça ok à vous de
faire votre choix il m'envoie chez merci
quand même merci boulevard bonmarché
Paris 3 sac à main de maroinerie et il
m'envoie chez le taneur ensuite
qu'est-ce que j'ai bien que non spécifi
dans les résas de recherche un manteau
de saison ou un blouson pourra être un
excellent choix ok ici Santa GPT peut
vous aider à venir faire vos achats de
Noël mais au-delà des achats de Noël
c'est valable également pour la
Saint-Valentin pour la Fête des Mères La
fête des pères pour un anniversaire bref
pour ce que vous voulez et ici chat GPT
peutre quand même d'excellents conseils
li partout et même chez le Père Noël
imaginez que vous puissiez demander au
Père Noël de dire un message
personnaliser à vos amis à vos enfants
c'est rendu possible grâce au WhatsApp
du Père Noël de BCK tellcom grâce à de
l'intelligence artificielle je vous mets
le lien juste en bas dans la description
pour venir l'essayer et sur WhatsApp
vous venez parler au Père Noël grâce à
allo Papa Noël par BCK TCOM vous met
déjà un petit message devinez qui est de
retour et oui c'est moi le Père Noël
cette année encore vivez la magie défête
en famille écrivez-moi un petit texte
personnalisé sans emoji pour vos enfants
et je l'enregistrerai en vidéo je vais
écrire un message pour mon fils et c'est
le Père Noël qui va le lire une fois que
vous avez fini de le rédiger et bien
vous l'envoyez vous recevez un message
quand votre nouvelle vidéo est prête
vous n'avez plus qu'à faire lecture et
écouterz le Père
Noël bonjour i as-tu bien été sage cette
année j'en suis persuadé j'ai décidé de
te gâter avec de jolis cadeaux à
commencé par un message personnalisé
créé grâce à de l'intelligence
artificielle et si le décor est choisi
aléatoirement mais si vous voulez vous
pouvez même vous venir choisir
directement le décor vous cliquez
ensuite sur vidéo du Père Noël
sélectionnez le décor et là vous
choisissez le salon le bureau les
cadeaux le traîneau la boutique et book
Telecom propose une nouveauté cette
année avec chat GPT le compte
personnalisé du Père Noël vous cliquez
sur compte personnalisé et là il vous
l'indique vous avez choisi la nouveauté
de cette année le compte de Noël
personnalisable pour que je l'enregistre
rien de plus simple envoyez-moi le
prénom de votre héros et je m'occupe du
reste on va mettre aussi Elliot merci
j'ai bien reçu son prénom pour continuer
de personnaliser le compte écrivez-moi
par exemple une activité ou un objet que
vous souhaitez voir apparaître dans
l'histoire on va marquer un robot super
votre compte est presque prêt j'ai
encore besoin d'un dernier mot de votre
choix pour enrichir le compte que je
vais créer pour notre héros et là je
vais marquer intelligence artificielle
on reste dans la thématique et j'envoie
patience je prépare votre compte votre
est prêt et vous avez plus qu'à
l'écouter il était une fois dans un loin
d'un pays enchanté vivait un petit
garçon noméen à soir alors qu'il
s'endormait une étoile filante traversa
le ciel à vous de jouer pour envoyer des
messages personnalisés du Père Noël ou
des comptes personnalisés avec le
WhatsApp du Père Noël de BCK telléecom
c'est facile et surtout très rapide
offrez de la magie à Noël grâce à BCK
tellecom deuxème astuce vous avez un
smartphone qui rame mais qui rame et
vous n'en pouvez plus une imprimante que
vous n'arrivez pas à à paramétrer une
tablette qui ne veut plus rien faire ou
alors carrément un problème avec votre
ordinateur et bien vous pouvez demander
des solutions ici directement à chatp
c'est très simple vous venez ici vous
allez dans explore et là vous allez dans
tech support Advisor et là il va venir
vous aider vous lui dites mon iphone RAM
que puis-je faire et on envoie la
question il est frustrant lorsque votre
iPhone ne fonctionne plus aussi
rapidement qu'il ne devrait voici
quelques étapes pour résoudre ce
problème première étape ça pourrait être
un tuto YouTube première étape
redémarrage de l'iPhone parfois un
simple redémarrage peut résoudre de
nombreux problème pour redémarrer
appuyez maintenez le bouton latéral et
l'un des boutons de volume jusqu'à ce
que le curseur éteindre apparaisse c'est
très très clair il vous guide réellement
faites glisser pour éteindre et rallumer
l'appareil après quelques secondes ok
deuxième astuce de chat GPT ici vérifier
l'espace de stockage c'est très très
clair un espace de stockage faible pour
ralentir votre iPhone aller dans réglage
général stockage iPhone pour vérifier
l'espace disponible supprimer les
application inutilisé les photos les
vidéos les fichiers pour libérer
l'espace astuce 3 que nous donne ici
chat GPT mise à jour log iiciel
assurez-vous que votre iPhone est est à
jour ah je avais marqué et la mise à
jour tu a fait une faute non est à jour
avec la dernière version d'iOS les mises
à jour peuvent inclure des améliorations
de performance pour vérifier règlage
général mise à jour logiciel
quatrièmement fermer des applications en
arrière-plan cinquièmement
réinitialiser les réglages et là il vous
dit où aller réglage général
réinitialiser réinitialiser tous les
réglages que les réglages et puis ça n'a
pas résolu votre problème 6e astuce qu'
vous donne ici restauration de l'iPhone
dernier recours vous pouvez restaurer
votre iPhone dans ses paramètres d'usine
assurez-vous de sauvegarder vos données
avant caracera tout le contenu de votre
appareil c'est extrêmement précis et là
je vous parle comme ça on peut lui dire
mon imprimante Canon j'en ai une canon
c'est pour ça que je mets ça ne
fonctionne plus que ce passe-t-il
lorsqu'une imprimante Canon cesse de
fonctionner cela peut être dû à
différents problèmes alors des problèmes
de connectivité à des problèmes
matériels vérifie l'alimentation
électrique basique vérifier les
connexions simple redémarrer
l'imprimante et l'ordinateur totalement
clair vérifier les erreurs d'imprimante
s'il y a des erreurs qui s'affichent sur
votre imprimante ou pas bourrage de
papier et compagnie mise à jour ou
réinstallation des pilote vérifier les
paramètres de l'imprimante nettoyer les
têtes d'impression enfin bref c'est très
très clair ça vous guide pas à pas sur
les problèmes les plus connus ici et
s'il y a d'autres problèm je pense qu'il
va falloir aller voir un réparateur mais
voyez ça vous permet vraiment de
dégrossir tous les problèmes troisème
astuce est-ce que vous savez que sur
Chat GPT il existe énormément de plugin
créés par des développeurs tiers qui
vous permettent de faire énormément de
choses alors je vous montre alors pour
ça faut une version payante de chat GPT
il faut aller sur Chat GPT 4 et là vous
venez dans plugin il y en a énormément
alors moi j'en ai installé quelques-uns
mais je vous montre vous allez dans le
plugin Store vous avez les plus
populaires les nouveaux vous les avez
tous et après vous avez ceux qui sont
installés il y en a quand même 131 pages
à l'heure actuel c'est pas mal dans les
plugins vous allez aller ici sur Expedia
et on va lui demander aide-moi à
planifier mon road trip entre Los
Angeles et San Francisco c'est une
excellente idée de faire un trip entre
Los Angeles Francisco merci pour
commencer voulez-vous je trouve un
hébergement à Los Angeles San Francisco
dans une autre ville le long de la route
je marqué dans une autre ville le long
de la route parfait pourrez-vous me dire
le nom de la ville où vous souhaitez
trouver un hébergement entre Los Angeles
cela me semble fir les meilleures
options je ne sais pas je te laisse
choisir selon les meilleures options
d'accord je vais choisir une ville
intéressante pour vous une option
populaire g et Santa Barbara on connaît
çabara connu pour ces plages magnifiqu
son architecture espagnole et ces
excellents vignobles ça vous convient
pour une escale ça me semble bien et là
il utilise maintenant expéia on retrouve
ici l'icône et puis on voit utilisation
de expéia voici trois options
d'hébergement à Santa Barbara pour votre
trip entre Los Angeles et San Francisco
on a l'hôtel Millo Santa Barbara
description profiteer de deux piscines
extérieur je pense que je vais me
cailler les miches et d'un accès direct
à la plage où vous pourrez jouer au
volet emplacement au cœur de Santa
Barbara B 3,5 étoil note des clients 7,8
prix moyen par nuit 200 dollars et j'ai
un lien pour réserver voyez ici je
clique sur le lien tac ça m'envoie sur
Expedia directement ils sont malins
quand même et là je vois l'hôtel j'ai
des photos je vois l'emplacement sur la
carte ça me paraît quand même plutôt pas
mal c'est assez joli ça donne très envie
ensuite il y a le in by the Hamburg
abord hôtel non fumeur piscine extérieur
centre de fitness centre d'affaires
voyez donc ça m'en propose plein je suis
un peu plus cher en tarif 9/10 au niveau
des des notes des clients ce Franciscan
hôel notes des clients également 9/ 10
c'est un peu moins cher ça peut être une
bonne option économiser 20 % pas mal et
là il me met le lien pour réserver bien
évidemment et on peut faire plein de
choses comme ça avec ces plugins alors
là vous avez Expedia mais il y en a
d'autres il y a kayak pour venir
réserver directement ici donc c'est
quand même pas mal foutu 4ème astuce
au-delà d'un voyage maintenant ce qu'on
veut c'est se remettre en forme pour
être beau justement sur la plage pendant
ce voyage là et bien on peut le faire
une fois de plus ici directement dans
les plugins vous restez ici dans le chat
GPT plugin et là vous allez venir aller
sur le plugin qui s'appelle workout
generérator et là vous lui dites je suis
un homme de 44 ans j'ai besoin de me
remettre en forme et je souhaite gagner
en masse musculaire propose-moi un
programme complet de remise en forme et
c'est parti donc la utilisation de
workout gérator voici un programme de
mise en forme conçu pour vous aider à
gagner masse musculaire et améliorer
votre condition physique générale merci
beaucoup ce programme est adapté à un
homme de 44 ans et peut-être réalisé à
domicile ce qui me va très très bien il
comprend une variété d'exercices ciblant
diff diff parties du corps ainsi que du
cardio pour maintenir le rythme
cardiaque élevé je suis au top titre du
programme entraînement intermédiaire de
force et de cardio alors on commence par
TR sets de pompes 15 répétitions voilà
on fait 15 pompes et on fait trois fois
je pense que ça doit être ça instruction
vidéo et ça c'est vachement bien parce
que lorsque vous cliquez dessus voyez
vous arrivez directement sur Youtube et
il vous montre comment bien faire vos
pompes qui est quand même globalement
vachement bien ici vous avez également
des instructions détaillées là vous
arrivez directement sur le site et
lorsque vous cliquez dessus de la même
manière vous allez avoir ici une vidéo
qui vous explique comment faire votre
pompe vous gardez votre dos bien droit
vous gagnez tous les les côtés c'est
beau c'est bien ensuite on fait des
squats bon alterre j'ai pas d'alterre
mais je peux quand même faire des squats
des fentes du rameur assis c'est un peu
plus galère à la maison le rameur assis
tout de suite des presses d'épaules en
position avec barre je n'ai pas de barre
bon je peux peut-être trouver un truc un
petit peu lourd peut-être pour pouvoir
le faire curl avec barre une fois de
plus j'ai pas de barre mais je peux
prendre des bouquins peut-être que ça
m'aidera ou alors je peux acheter les
altteres pour la maison également pompe
avec rotation latérale 30 répétitions 37
SAU sur place avec lev de genoux durer 3
minutes donc là en cardio je vais
morfler et pour de meilleurs résultats
assurez-vous de suivre une alimentation
équilibrée et de vous reposer
suffisamment donc ça c'est quand même
vachement bien une fois de plus et ça
vous le faites directement à l'intérieur
de chat GPT 5è astuce vous voulez faire
le résumé d'une vidéo Youtube ça peut
être pour un exposé pour votre culture
personnelle bref pour ce que vous voulez
une vidéo par exemple qui dure une
demi-heure à 1 heure et vous avez pas
envie de passer une demi-heure à 1 heure
en regardant cette vidéo ou pourquoi pas
juste pour avoir un aperçu de cette
vidéo est-ce que ça vaut le coup de le
regarder est-ce que le contenu va me
plaire je veux absolument un résumé et
vous pouvez l'avoir ici directement dans
le chat GPT toujours de la même manière
vous restez dans les plugins et vous
allez aller sur Youtube summerizer avec
mon très très bel accent vous trouvez
votre vidéo YouTube par exemple celle-là
faismoi un résumé de cette vidéo vous
balancez le lien et vous envoyez la
purée on voit qu'il est en train de
bosser en utilisant directement le
plugin YouTube summerider la vidéo
titulé qui est Monsieur Greux sur la
chaîne Youtube monsieur Greux est une
présentation personnelle de Monsieur
Greux mais c'est moi voici un résumé de
la vidéo il se présente et parle de sa
passion pour une nouvelle techno il
raconte son histoire montrant de images
de lui-même à différents âges y compris
lorsqu'il avait moins de cheveux blancs
ou je vous cache pas c'est vrai il
mentionne ses première expérience avec
technologie son premier amstrade à 11
ans Game Boy Super Nintendo premier
iPhone en 2008 il parle également de son
goût pour le champagne bien que cela ne
sont pas directement lié à la
technologie c'est clair expérience en
radio plusieurs entreprises il exprime
qu'au fond il a toujours été passionné
par la technologie donc il montre qu'il
a voyagé dans différentes villes il a
fait de nombreuses rencontres avec des
expériences cont ses voyages la vidéo se
termine sur des images de lui réalisant
son rêve d'enfance et en plongeant au
cœur des nouvelles technologies la vidéo
été vue
139531 fois dure 2 minutes et 37
secondes c'est extrêmement précis ça
c'est quand même vachement bien si vous
avez des vidéos très longues elle est
courte celle-là mais si vous avez une
vidéo très longue vous dites est-ce que
je vais trouver un contenu qui va
m'intéresser à l'intérieur vous pouvez
passer directement ici comme ça vous
avez un peu une vue d'ensemble vous
dites ah ouais ouais ce qu'il y a dedans
ça m'intéresse maintenant je vais
regarder et ça c'est quand même pas mal
parce que des fois ça fait raller de
peut-être perdre une demi-heure voire
une heure pour la 6e astuce est-ce que
vous saviez que vous pouvez parler
directement un chat GPT pas besoin de
Prom pas besoin de taper pas besoin
d'écrire vous vous metettez pas vous lui
parlez directement il vous répondra il
ou elle ça peut dépendre de la voix vous
répondra pour se faire c'est très simple
vous allez directement dans
l'application chat GPT et là juste en
bas vous allez retrouver une petite
icône là en forme de casque il vous lui
posez une question qui est kit dans
K2000 kit dans la série télévisée k 2000
est en réalité la voiture elle-même kit
est l'acronyme de Night
industries ce qui signifie industries
night 2000 en français c'est une voiture
hautement avancée dotée d'une
intelligence artificielle avancée qui
peut parler et interagir avec son pilote
Michael Knight joué par David Hassel kit
est un personnage EMBL ématique de la
série en raison de ses capacités
technologiques et de son apparence
distinctive moi ce que je trouve
vraiment génial c'est que vous avez un
aspect visuel et c'est pour ça que je
lui pose la question de kit de K2000
parce que j'ai vraiment l'impression de
retrouver ça en fait cette espèce
d'interface visuelle que vous avez là
vous allez voir chat GPT pouvoir
interagir directement avec et je trouve
ça juste oufissim parce que ça change
totalement l'expérience ce qui nous
emmène à la 7è astuce c'est la vision de
chat GPT chat GPT pourra vous aider à
énormément de choses notamment à venir
identifier un produit pour se faire ici
il faut aller une fois de plus dans GPT
4 avec 3.5 ça marche pas vous cliquez
sur la petite icône juste en bas ici et
vous venez prendre une photo là on va
prendre la boîte du S23 fe et Tac on
fait la photo quel est ce smartphone
c'est très simple c'est bête c'est écrit
dessus il s'agit d'un smartphone Samsung
Galaxy S23 fe selon l'image de la boîte
que vous avez partagé alors ici l'idée
c'était pas de le piéger avec une
question trop compliquée mais de bien
voir qu'il est totalement en capacité de
venir lire ce qui a écrit et je trouve
ça une fois de plus extrêmement bluffant
parce qu'on peut venir enrichir
totalement la vision de chat GPT il sa
c'est voir il sait analyser il sait
reconnaître et ce qu'on peut imaginer en
faire après est juste complètement
dingue si on vient juste donner des yeux
à chat GPT è astuce je veux améliorer
mon régime alimentaire je veux mieux
m'alimenter je sais pas comment faire et
j'ai pas envie de m'embêter je vais donc
demander à chat GPT le mieux c'est de
faire sur Chat GPT 4 mais on peut
également le faire sur le 3.5 bon chat
GPT 4 et on va surtout venir lui parler
ben oui maintenant qu'on sait qu'on peut
lui parler on va le faire on appuie donc
ici sur cette petite icône et on lui
explique mon cher chat GPT j'ai une
question à te poser je suis un homme
j'ai 44 ans et je m'alimente
relativement mal à base de patate de
pâtes et de fromage fondu c'est pas
terrible je souhaite améliorer mon
régime alimentaire peux-tu me faire un
programme du lundi au dimanche avec une
alimentation saine et équilibrée pour le
matin le midi et le soir bien sûr je
vais te proposer un programme
alimentaire sain et équilibré pour
chaque jour je te donnerai une idée pour
le petit-déjeuner le déjeuner et le
dîner ça te convient-il c'est parfait
merci d'accord voici ton programme oui
c'est pas mal ça pourrait gagner encore
un petit peu en fluidité mais comme
c'est fait là c'est quand même vachement
efficace Yaour nature déjeuner salade de
quinois avec légumes grillé et poulet
dîner saumon au four brocoli et ribbrin
mardi petit déjeuner smoothie vert avec
bon il va vous faire tout le programme
comme ça toutes les idées c'est quand
même plutôt pas mal et je trouve ça une
fois de plus extrêmement bluffant que ce
soit chat GPT qui vienent m'aider comme
ça allez 9e astuce et pas des moindres
votre copine votre copain vient de vous
larger ça ne va pas du tout et vous
voulez le ou la récupérer bien vous
faites quoi vous pouvez demander à chat
GPT de la même manière et bien on vient
là et on va lui dire chat GPT ça va pas
du tout il y a ma copine qui m'a largué
je pense qu'elle m'aime encore un peu
que puis-je faire pour raviver la flamme
je suis désolé d'apprendre que vous
traversez une période difficile si vous
pensez qu'il y a encore des sentiments
entre vous une approche sincère et
respectueuse pourrait' aider vous
pourriez envisager de lui écrire une
lettre pour exprimer vos sentiments
honnêtement ouais ok en lui faisant part
de ce que vous appréciez chez elle et
les bons moments passés ensemble
voulez-vous des conseils sur comment
écrire cette lettre oui dis-moi comment
écrire la lettre pour écrire une lettre
qui exprime vos sentiments voici
quelques conseils commencer par un ton
chaleureux et personnel utiliseer son
prénom et une salutation qui reflète
votre relation exprimer vos sentiments
sincèrement dites-lui ce que vous
ressentez mais sans être trop intant ah
oui pas trop int par exemple vous
pourriez dire je me suis rendu compte à
quel point tu compte pour moi ah oui
ouis je m'en suis rendu compte pour
partager les bons souvenirs mentionner
des moments spécifiques que vous avez
partagé bon ok on arrête là on a donc un
chat GPT expert en séduction qui va vous
aider à retrouver l'ame sœur pour
renouer une relation forte on voit donc
qu'il y a énormément de choses qu'on
peut venir faire et qu'on ne soupçonnez
pas ici avec chat GPT je trouve ça très
cool d'ailleurs dites-moi vous quel est
l'astuce que vous préférez parmi les
neuf que je vous ai présenté puis bien
évidemment on peut aller encore plus
loin avec l'intelligence artificielle
encore au-delà de chat GPT cette vidéo
vous aidera à découvrir plein
d'intelligence artificiel croyez-moi
vous m'en direz des
nouvelles